[Music]
we started from tehran in the intention
of prosecuting our tour
in europe it is now a whole year since
information was given of this
intended tour in europe and it is also
some days that we have been suffering
from a
pain in the chest and the severe cold in
the head so as to be very unwell
the sensations of fatigue and weakness
to so great a degree that i've never
experienced the like before
placing my trust in god however i
sallied forth
[Music]
[Applause]
in the morning whilst i slept as they
said the train passed through a hole in
the mountain
after a short interval we came to
another hole of a thousand
four hundred l's long and as dark as
night it occupies six minutes to
traverse it
the populousness and the cultivation in
the land of the prussian are greater
than in russia
whenever i looked out there were
villages houses men oxen
horses mares sheep meadows sewn fields
and flowers of all colours
at last we reached the station and
delighted his most exalted majesty the
emperor of germany
william the nawab the heir apparent also
prince bismarck the famous
chancellor of germany marshall roon the
minister of war and premiere of prussia
and general mulcai now marshall and
generalissimo
very celebrated and much spoken of were
there to receive us
they gave us the most cordial reception
in germany the women are very much
occupied in business and at work
especially at agriculture and in
gardening they do labor
much more than their husbands in berlin
and in other towns
the little boys fastened soldiers
knapsacks onto their own backs
run about the streets and play on fifes
how excellent it is that they from
infancy upwards thus learn to be
soldiers
although the beggars of ferangistan
instead of asking for arms
play musical instruments such as guitars
or violins
and never beg if someone gives them
money they take it
if not they go on playing
on our passage we remarked a singular
pastime which they had devised
they had fitted up a kind of gypsy tent
and around the tent there were
pasteboard carriages and horses
on which people's children rode while
the tent
revolved incessantly causing the
carriages the horses and their riders
to go round also
after dinner we went to the theater a
beautiful house with five tiers of seats
about the size of the michael theatre at
st
petersburg the audience was crowded the
play was a
ballet this evening and they danced well
the dancers wore
strange costumes i in the emperor went
onto the stage and
looked around a little we then returned
and another scene commenced
they danced and represented some
interesting situations
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
so coco's super excited because she gets
to go out and about this summer after
being trapped inside for so long
coco what are you most excited about
this summer
not seeing my stupid face 24 hours a day
thanks goku luckily magellan gives coco
lots of other things to look at
one recommendation i enjoyed recently
was the last empress
a fascinating study of the history of
iran and this iconic woman
a great companion piece for this video
and one of more than 3
000 documentaries available and you can
now take advantage of an exclusive offer
thirty percent off an annual membership
this gives you an entire year for less
than three dollars fifty a month even if
you've joined magellan before
and lapsed you can simply click on the
link in the description
to claim your discounted membership
today
thanks
[Music]
the train traveled at so furious a rate
that it was impossible for one to
distinguish any place
we went on until we reached the
beginning of the city of
london again it is impossible to
describe the prosperity the populousness
the extent of the city the numbers of
lines of railway of which
incessantly the trains come and go in
every direction the smoke of the
factories and the like
we traveled over the exteriors of the
rules of the houses and thus we reached
the station
and stopped the country in england has
no resemblance to that in other
territories
it has much forest large trees
population without interval
and cultivation enormous the wealth of
the english is famous
throughout the world there is no need to
describe it here
here was an assemblage of spectators and
a crowd beyond all limits
there were the armor wearing english
household cavalry there was the nawab
the heir apparent of england
known as the prince of wales and the
whole of the ministry
of the notables and of the nobles were
present the crowd of spectators was
never ending
the population of the city is said to be
over 80 crores of souls
it has most lovely women the nobleness
the greatness
the gravity and sedateness of the women
and men shine out from their
countenances
one sees and comprehends that they are a
great people
and that the lord of the universe has
bestowed upon them power and might sense
and wisdom and enlightenment thus it is
that they have conquered a country like
india and hold important possessions in
america and elsewhere
in the world their soldiers are very
strong of frame and beautifully attired
their armor-wearing household cavalry
are very strong and handsome young men
exquisitely dressed like the cavalry in
russia
[Music]
we had reached the half of our ride when
a heavy rain set in
and wet the people through and through i
myself was also a good deal moistened
but i requested and the carriage was
closed in part
the grand vizier and lord morley
remained exposed to the rain
so that they were wet through
we arrived to our destination buckingham
palace
where quarters were allotted to us and
there we are lighted
this palace is the town residence of the
sovereign
it is a very imposing and extensive
structure the air apparent and the other
princes accompanied us
and led us to the palace there is an
extensive and beautiful garden in front
of this palace
with magnificent lawns and beautifully
kept
they have a kind of reaping machine like
a cart and drawn by a horse
this cuts down the grass in strips and
collects it
into the cart we have to go to windsor
castle
the residence of her most exalted
majesty victoria
sovereign of england which is one hour's
journey by rail
passing along the drive in hyde park and
through the town we reached the station
and took our seat in the train we
traversed inhabited places the open
country
and green meadows and a length windsor
castle rose to view at a distance
appearing like a fortress with four
turrets
[Music]
her most exalted majesty the sovereign
advanced to meet us at the foot of the
staircase
we got down took her hand gave our arm
went up the stairs
passed through pretty rooms and
corridors hung with beautiful portraits
and entering a private apartment took
our seat
the age of the sovereign is 50 but she
looks no more than 40.
she's very cheerful and pleasant of
countenance the sovereign of england
keeps a book
in which each person who goes to windsor
castle to see her inscribes his name
i too wrote mine today
at one point the english fire brigade
came and in the garden at the back of
our palace went through their exercise
they planted ladders with the
supposition that the upper floor of the
palace was on fire
they mounted these ladders with perfect
celerity and agility
and brought down people who were burnt
half burnt or unharmed
some taken upon their shoulders and
others let down by ropes
made fast around their waist they've
invented a beautiful means of saving men
but the wonder is in this that on the
one hand they take such
trouble and originate such appliances
for the salvation of man from death
when on the other hand in the armouries
arsenals and workshops of
woolwich and of crop in germany they
contrive
fresh engines such as cannons muskets
projectiles and similar things for the
quicker and more multitudinous slaughter
of the human race
he whose invention destroys man more
surely and
expeditiously prides himself there on
and obtains
decorations of honor
a short repose soon enabled us to set
out again and drive to madame two swords
exhibition
madame tussaud was a woman and has now
been dead for 20 years having left a son
and grandson
[Music]
she originated a place in which i
arranged the
effigies in wax of monarchs of men and
celebrity and of great poets
ancient and modern clothed in the very
garments for the persons themselves or
of their periods
whether they were men or women even to
artificial jewels
such as crowns necklaces finger rings
and the like
these figures are arranged in rooms and
halls in standing or sitting postures
and in such a manner that there is no
possibility for one to distinguish
whether they are living beings
or wax figures
there were some living women sitting
about among the figures and however much
i tried to distinguish which were in
reality human beings
and which were wax figures i could not
until the women rose
walked and smiled then alone did it
become certain
that they were living women
they had bought in france a guillotine
on which by hanging they put people to
death
and placed it here to show the manner of
killing men they said
that with this guillotine nearly 20 000
individuals had been executed
after resting a while we drove to the
albert hall we therefore went to some
halls where they had made a collection
of tobacco pipes
hubble bubbles and drinking utensils of
every nation
having viewed these we went up from that
place to see the pictures which people
during the three months the exhibition
remains open bring in hang up here
a picture of a donkey was seen and i
asked the price of it
the director of the exhibition a fat
white bearded man
told me it was a hundred pounds sterling
i remarked the value of a live donkey is
at the outside five pounds
how is it then that this which is but a
picture of an ass
is to be paid so dearly for the director
said
because it is not a source of expense as
it eats neither straw
nor barley i replied true it is not a
source of outlay but neither will it
carry a load
or give one a ride we laughed heartily
[Music]
from london to liverpool is five hours
journey in a distance of 50 leagues
today the train passed through many
holes in mountains the ground being
extremely hilly and intersected with
valleys
everywhere we found wood screen fields
cultivation and populousness
the city of liverpool is one of the
great cities ports and commercial marts
of england and does business chiefly
with america from whence it principally
draws wheat and cotton
the wheat crop of england is not
sufficient for the food of its
inhabitants
emigrants in large numbers embark at
this port for america
coming from england germany and
elsewhere according to what was learnt
more than
two hundred thousand immigrants annually
leave this port
for the new world not one of whom ever
returns
the region of firangistan has an
important company for the expedition
of immigrants in proportion to the
inhabitants of london
many more poor people were noticed in
these parts on whose countenances were
visibly stamped the signs that they
obtained a living
with difficulty
[Music]
today we have to reach paris we rose
early in the morning went down into a
boat
and pushed off for the shore the weather
was very cold
the majority of the women and men in
france are small maid and
attenuated of lim they are not like the
inhabitants of russia germany and
england
but more resemble the people of the east
today we noticed a singular frame of
mind in the french
first of all they still keep up the
state of mourning that follow the german
war
and they are all young or old sorrowful
and melancholy
the dresses of the women ladies and men
are all dresses used for mourning with
little
ornamentation and very plain now and
again some of the people shouted
vive the shah of persia from another one
i heard as i strolled about at nighter a
loud voice saying
may his reign and rule be firm and
enduring from the whole of these
circumstances it becomes evident that
there are at present in france
numerous parties who desire a monarchy
but they are in three sections one
desiring the son of napoleon
another the dynasty of louis philippe
and the third henry v
the wishes for a republic on the other
hand have great power
but they are not all of one mind some
are for a red republic which is a
fundamental commonwealth others are for
a moderate republic in which monarchical
institutions shall be found
without a monarch existing others again
wish otherwise
then france is the most powerful of
states and all must take her into their
calculations
although with these dissidences it is a
difficult matter for her to preserve
her institutions
the celebrated rothschild a jew also who
is exceedingly rich
came to an audience and we conversed
with him he greatly advocated the cause
of the jews
mentioned the jews of persia and claimed
tranquility for them
i said to him i've heard that you
brothers
possess a thousand crores of money i
consider the best thing to do
would be that you should pay 50 crores
to some large or small state
and buy a territory in which you could
collect all the jews of the whole world
you becoming their chiefs and leading
them on their way in peace
so that you should be no longer thus
scattered
and dispersed we laughed heartily and he
made no reply
i gave him an assurance that i do
protect every
alien nationality that is in persia
[Music]
you